yeah hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing Rubik 87 okay okay against
therefore I have this somewhat weird
move fd6 yeah it's not too bad
okay can play many moves of course
against this opening but this is a
somewhat unconventional way of doing it
it's not too bad yeah yeah I tried to
get into a Scandinavian where f4 is
fairly useless and maybe rather yeah not
helping wide at all let's see how he
handles it do I threaten queenie for
winning appalled maybe yeah I came this
was very much to be expected so it's
it's like a Scandinavian with f1 I don't
know what what that means let's see
maybe maybe you should just go h3 and
try to expand yeah it's it's hard for me
not to take then hmm
yeah probably h3 takes Queen takes I
have to go something like knight c6 I
think c6 is probably a bit too passive
yeah one thing I know we cannot Castle
and that Quincy five wins the bishop but
let's see maybe a knight c6 base setup
is best here anyway it could be possible
just try to put pressure on deform or
fight for that square put pressure it's
probably a little bit weird way to put
it okay
so why can I not take this probably I
can it's not like it's terrible and then
he wants to take on f7 and play 95 oh
wow that's interesting but at the end I
can take f4 in this liner I take Nagi
for Queen f4 yeah that is not not a big
problem
so you aid or g8 g8 yeah it looks a bit
scary but
don't see why not
that was um
when I was thinking I can take this and
with the queen taking here it's not like
why this yeah getting mobilized all that
quickly if he takes on f6 now he takes
I'm actually rather quick and playing
the night out and playing the p8 myself
this is also why I went to g8 and not to
e8 the only thing that's kind of
troublesome is that a check sum check
here is made yeah I didn't see how this
would would would work how I could I
mean they get this get this in yeah most
obvious move is Queen e5 you know I
think this is also good I mean yes no
good move really 92 blunders rook king
f2 is Bishop c5 Knight it what do you do
Queenie to him okay and now I'm just
going to trade come on
that's easy an easy move to play really
nothing fancy necessary
yeah I think that check I can cannot
hurt now
mmm me I cannot go a six which would
have been nice
okay I don't think rookie aid was
necessarily the best okay let's go
Bishop d6 even though after taking
Bishop a3 it feels like it helped white
slightly okay
yes I still think I'll keep the pawn g8
rook f5
I've got D for you
yeah there's some way to try to use that
somewhat unstable piece but it doesn't
really threaten all that much at the end
of the day this one yeah here I've got
Knight c4 I thought maybe this is not
too big a deal or just King e6 and play
d4
yeah that's maybe even stronger
maybe it isn't stronger ok rooks c4
maybe prevent defines get this one if
possible no I had no time and absolutely
no time yeah I don't know this ISM these
six is an original way of handling f4
it's um
yeah it's nothing special but it is
quite a playable option yeah you have
this on the Raider but also ask white
for a move and some moves are not that
it doesn't really help some of this e5
looks a bit odd and 93 is certainly most
natural Bishop g4 then II for again now
I can play this g5 as I did end and
there is also a six and then d5
sometimes this can lead to a position
that looks a bit like an advanced Cairo
with the bishop outside of the pawn
chain it's just a non theoretical way to
play so d5 and yeah I'm really not
certain yeah h3 is stronger
it's it I kind of have this hunch that
it could be a problem because I have to
take cannot go back and here I'm sorry
b7 hangs knight c6 MP should be five it
looks it doesn't look good so I probably
have to do this in this particular
situation and your wife must be better
just got more space just have some more
space yeah so probably d5 is not really
great yeah Bishop c4 yeah before it's an
interesting move I didn't really think
about it if I was thinking here here and
maybe now knight c6 is more
of an option but again we should be v is
strong you know
okay Queen b6 and it's not good to go to
position yeah
okay play before after which I have to
take I think it's okay to take let's put
it like that way yeah this this doesn't
really net wide much you take and now
Queen e2 is best and giving some
compensation actually this threatens
made here it's sorry yeah probably I
have to do queenie 5 then 94s is funny
I'm the funny move I cannot take the
rook has told you to mate and I have to
go h6 yeah no clue white certainly has
compensation yeah my position is really
a bit bit shaky you have a team after
this I'm yeah I'm a much better yeah
just a pawn basically and the white
bishop is kind of useless it's not
attacking anything and it won't attack
anything anytime soon Pentium and white
is falling apart completely the 86 is
playable against f1 but probably not the
best move okay guys thanks for watching